Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 30th,
2018 what's going on?
How,
AH,
um,
I'm a little bit late here with this podcast.
Um,
you know,
I was out there and Houston,
Texas for two nights in Dallas for one and I want to thank everybody that came
out and uh,
the weather was great.
It wasn't that hot,
you know,
I mean it was hot,
but it wasn't like Texas hot when we flew into Houston.
I saw,
you know,
a nice green fucking grass and that shit,
I didn't realize Houston was right on the water.
I always thought you still had to drive like an hour before you get to the Gulf
of Mexico.
I don't think I ever looked at that.
And I know a lot of,
yeah,
Ooh,
boom.
No I didn't.
I didn't want to watch a bunch of people losing their houses.
Did you watch it with your fucking popcorn before there was that disaster?
Did you know that it sat right on the Gulf?
Unless you live there,
that's actually,
you know,
something.
Every time I go to a,
um,
a state,
I kind of look where everything's positioned in and it's self fucked.
How,
like your brain remembers it,
Nick.
I always thought Austin was in between Houston and San Antonio.
Turns out it isn't,
it's north just northeast to San Antonio on the 35.
And then like a,
you know,
fucking San Antonio and Houston and kind of parallel with one another.
And of course,
Dallas is all the way up there on top Dallas,
Texas,
where the heat is real and the titties ain't.
Um,
I had an awesome time when I was up there.
And guess what,
guess what old freckles has done?
He hasn't drank this whole month.
Oh,
did he want one last night?
But he didn't.
Um,
I'm going to,
yeah.
This is my new thing.
I'm drinking the way I smoke cigars once every 10 to 14 days.
If I do that,
if I do that alone,
I will cut down on my drinking by at least 172%.
No,
I don't know what I would do.
Um,
that's the game plan.
So I got a little,
uh,
little,
little Shindig August 7th.
Then I go right back on the wagon until fucking,
I'm gonna try to go back on the wagon.
That's the hardest thing for me.
Once I go off a whole daddy's playing the game again.
Oh,
he's,
he's in the game.
You get a little dirt on his beautiful.
Um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
Nate Craig was out there with me crushing it every single night.
And um,
I dunno,
don't have anything bad to say,
but it was weird.
It was weird going to Dallas and that's sending a vignette texts.
Other than that,
it was a good time.
Um,
all right.
They're just bum me out.
Why would I bum you up?
Good News.
Hey,
you know,
something,
his taste is something that you,
you might not have known about me,
but since when you were in my presence is,
I swear to God,
if I wasn't a comedian,
I could have been a manager.
Well,
at least I could.
I could have been a talent scout,
you know,
telling you how many more do I have to call?
Remember long time ago I said,
you know,
I've been watching this drummer on Instagram at the pocket queen.
Well,
that drum is going to be sitting in with the Seth Meyers show all this week.
What did I say?
Go ahead.
Go back and look at the old podcast.
Listen to them.
We're just right there.
I could have done it.
I could've brought the red socks out of there.
Fuck at age six,
year curse earlier.
If they had me as a talent scout,
I could just see now I can't see it in sports.
I can't see everyone.
Whatever,
you know,
you don't.
It really is.
You make a fun fucking thousand guesses and then one of them comes in and then
what you really do is you just brag about it,
which is,
which is what I'm doing.
So anyways,
I'm back out here in Los Angeles.
All right.
I'm sitting in a very progressive manner.
MMM.
You don't want to watch.
Last night I watched a couple episodes of,
uh,
Seinfeld's new,
comedians in cars.
You got to see the Brian Regan won the Dave Chappelle one is awesome.
It's Dave Chappelle.
But this Seinfeld one,
the car that Brian Regan likes,
I actually like it too,
but it's a 2005,
like two Cedar Cadillac or something like that.
The level with I on all the episodes.
I've never seen Seinfeld shit on a car.
Like he shut on that car
from the way it looked to the options to describing the person that was going to
drive it.
Um,
and then Reagan of course it was Reagan and he was fucking hilarious.
But I was kind of hoping he was going to bring up how much he did not care for
Brian's tastes and cars.
But you should check it out if you get a chance.
So anyways,
is my story.
So I'm in Houston,
right.
And I was supposed to fly up to Dallas and once again I fucked up.
I wanted to fly into love field cause that's the smaller one in Dallas,
the and whatever,
that fucking Metro airport,
whatever the hell it is.
It's gigantic.
But this time I actually went through Dallas airport and it,
it was,
it was really easy.
Oh I know why.
Because that wasn't connecting,
connecting through Dallas.
She always got to get on that fucking monorail.
And I swear to God,
if you're,
if you're in terminal B,
your connecting flight is in terminal a and you always have to go all the way
around.
You always miss it.
Just buy one share.
You could grab your bags and start running through the airport,
you know,
like Oj Simpson back in the day,
I guess,
you know,
maybe that's an option.
I don't know.
Um,
so anyways,
I was going to fly from Houston,
but uh,
Nate didn't get a ticket,
thought we were driving up,
so it was like,
God,
fuck it.
You know what?
I can't remember last time I took the 45 north up to,
uh,
from Houston to Dallas and uh,
canceled my fight flight.
We just fucking drove up there.
And um,
I gotta tell you,
man,
that is a,
uh,
it's an intense state.
Dallas,
Not Dallas,
Texas.
I mean,
there's just like nothing out there and then all of a sudden you just,
you finally fucking come on something.
You get so fucking excited.
Some sort of barbecue.
Joy,
Mike,
Mike and I,
we should stop there,
man.
You're the middle of nowhere.
Everything starts looking good.
Look at how they got fireworks.
Let's pull over man.
Got To get some of those.
I haven't seen anything.
Any sun is civilization for the last fucking hour.
Uh,
but we ended up stopping at this gas station where they got this checklist,
Slovakia,
Aki and a Slovakian.
I don't want to start any fucking wars over there.
Um,
little,
uh,
dessert thing that they have that some people put meat in,
some people put fruit in it or whatever.
And I only see him in Texas.
It's usually when I'm on the 35,
right around Waco,
Texas.
Um,
I was joking about that guy all weekend.
You know,
Joel Olsteen.
I was teasing those people down in Houston going like,
I can't believe you guys were surprised that that guy didn't let you into his
house when the hurricane cave.
He's,
he's selling out a basketball arena talking about Jesus.
Do you think this guy's even remotely honest on any level?
Let's do that thing where I had my eyes closed going.
Jesus doesn't want you to step on my blue rug.
I'm
talking about David Koresh anyways.
Was that was named David Kresh.
Really good looking guy,
man.
You remind me of that guy that who started in California,
California occasion.
He's also written,
uh,
um,
the x files.
David Duchovny,
sort of the David Duke Company.
Sort of understated by with them with like Richard Gere's here.
What was that?
I got more of a Rambo haircut,
you know,
I gotta look it up now.
Be like,
if you could go back in time,
we go hey to the cops,
right before that guy went nuts.
Hey man,
you got to get this guy.
He's saying he's Jesus.
Oh,
what's he look like?
Uh,
you know,
he kind of looks like a skeletal Rambo Haircut like David did.
Covenant with just a splash or Richard Gere.
Sounds like a cover of people magazine from Phuket,
1989.
Um,
what,
what are you looking up,
David Koresh?
The K factor?
He definitely would have got the plane ticket to Vegas.
Look at the guy.
You know what I mean?
If you tick off those fucking glad.
He looks like he could have done that.
Bjorn Borg story is what's going to freak me out.
How long did this guy live from 1959 to 1923 Oh Jesus.
Oh,
he's 33.
You know those Jesus freaks.
That's when they like to die.
Oh Geez.
Is died at 33.
So if I fucking die too then that means I'm just as his father or to make no
sense.
I thought it was going to come out on Sun anyways.
Um,
so I'd been eating perfectly the whole weekend and then I stopped and I got a
couple of those uh,
with,
I didn't know what the fuck they called.
Checklists allow Hannis I'm going to get you the name of them.
I can't find it.
It was called like a collage or something like that.
What the fuck?
Come on.
There it is.
Kol a c h e.
Oh my God.
That the delicious.
Hey Nia.
Wait,
who's that?
Hey.
Hey Buddy.
Oh,
you've got your book.
You want me to read you a story baby?
Oh,
is it?
Hi Buddy.
Can I get a kiss?
All right.
Oh,
the boss baby.
Did you guys like to listen?
A little freckles Riccio kids book.
Oh,
you did?
Okay.
I don't touch that.
Don't touch that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you.
I appreciate you showing me that was there.
Yeah.
I have to do a podcast,
man.
I don't know if I could do this right now.
All right.
From the moment the baby arrived,
it was obvious that he was the boss.
Yeah.
He looks like he put mom and dad on a round the clock schedule with no time off.
Thank you.
Does this seem familiar Kiddo?
Um,
bombing with her right now and then he set up his office right smack dab in the
middle of the house.
She's not even listening to me.
I have like no charisma here whatsoever.
She's finding the crap on my couch way.
My interesting,
he made demands many,
many demands.
And you've got a little Trump suit on and he was quite particular.
No,
I don't like that.
If things weren't done to his satisfaction,
he had a fit.
Well,
it sounds like these parents need to pooch kick him into his crib.
He conducted meetings lots and lots and lots of meetings.
Hey,
I eat,
are you interested in this at all?
I had to get back to my podcast.
Keep reading.
All right.
Many of the meetings happen in the middle of the night.
The funky thing,
when was this written,
Marla?
Prezi.
Is that an old black woman,
Marla?
The funky thing that came out of nowhere is it the 70s read the book.
He never ever said a single word that made any sense,
but that didn't stop.
She wants to run around.
Do you want to look at this?
I just feel like everybody's fast forwarding through this.
Oh,
whoa.
All right.
And then daddy went back to his podcast.
The end.
Is that cool?
Bye.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
I have to get back to a particularly excrutiatingly unfunny podcasts.
I'd been recording anytime I start and I start like promoting something or
whatever the hell I just did.
I had it.
My whole brain just goes out the damn window.
Do you want me to read that book again?
Okay.
Sorry guys.
This is just part of it.
Not The boss baby by Marla phrase
from the moment the baby.
All right,
let me get back to this.
So
bye bye bye.
Say I love you.
There you go.
She can't say it.
She just goes and Yang,
Yang,
Yang.
Um,
she yesterday after,
uh,
I flew back from Dallas,
um,
I landed at lax and I met a friend of mine,
believe it or not,
um,
who owns one of those Vietnam era fucking helicopters,
the Huey ewh ones.
And uh,
he was there with this instructor and they picked me up in the thing.
I literally at least sounded like I was in fucking apocalypse now.
And um,
you know,
he flew around off the coast of Malibu and all that stuff and then we landed at
this small airport,
got some lunch and then they let me fly it.
And uh,
it was amazing.
You know,
it's funny,
they,
old people always said,
if he can fly in our 22,
you can fly anything.
Um,
they are 22 is the little egg beater that I fly and it's kind of like driving a
car.
I would say like no power steering or power brakes.
You,
you're really doing it.
Um,
but despite all that,
anytime you get a new helicopter,
it's like,
it's not just like,
no,
if you would just to like,
if someone was to like taxi it out for you and you just took off,
it's very easy to fly anything.
But it's like when you come to a hover,
you know,
and you're doing little turns and stuff and trying to set it down on the pad.
I don't,
I don't know.
That's when I sit there thinking like that,
you know?
Okay,
you might be able to fly it,
but I don't think he can maneuver it.
Well.
So,
uh,
we just did it some pad work and then I flew from a camera Rio all the way out
to,
uh,
to Burbank.
It was amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
And um,
I want to thank my buddy Phil.
Let me do it.
Not naming any names or any of that crap that was speaking about helicopters.
Everybody keeps telling me I got to see that new Tom Cruise mission impossible.
Doesn't it seem like my podcasts lately that I'm throwing in advertising.
I swear to God I'm not.
I watched that movie.
Uh,
okay.
the,
uh,
the death of Stalin yesterday on the plane.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know who the hell wrote that man.
How do you turn that guy into a comedy?
But somehow they did with those fucking hilarious,
um,
two of my favorites of all time,
Steve Buscemi and a Jeffrey tambor or rent it.
They are absolutely hilarious and I wish I knew the name of the one of the other
league cronies there.
MMM.
Fucking amazing movie.
This,
this fuck.
You know what it is?
I don't have my fucking headphones.
I don't have a microphone.
I just,
I'm,
I this is,
this is like,
this is like Kryptonite.
Yeah.
I'm under the fucking gun.
I got to go fucking meet somebody.
I got it.
I got no time.
We'll feel maybe if you weren't driving and flying around and fucking amazing
helicopters,
you a whole and recorded this yesterday,
we wouldn't have listened as menial cause shit.
Eh,
um,
hey,
this week I'm going to be at rough and rowdy.
Rough and rowdy brawl.
August 5th is podcast is nothing but promotion in fucking.
Um,
what the hell am I going to be in a Youngstown,
Ohio.
You can preorder the fight@roughandrowdybrawl.com.
Okay.
Rough.
The letter n rowdy brawl.
Dot.
Calm.
Uh,
they got a pride verse prejudice.
They have a gay pat is going to be fighting this ex felon who doesn't like gays.
That's the uh,
that's the title fight.
And then we have a cop fighting a skateboarder.
Um,
you know,
and then there's also a bunch of a bunch of Cleveland Brown fans and Steeler
fans that want to beat the shit out of each other.
And uh,
it's all done in the name of fun.
How do you not sit and watch that man?
It's a,
it's like a tough man compe competition but with stories
and it's really never ready.
The kind of people that you could,
you could,
uh,
the match ups with how much people don't get along.
You know,
you could have neighbor,
verse,
neighbor,
uh,
you get in the gay community,
you could go with ex boyfriends and girlfriends,
you know,
cause then it's still chicken shit guy on guy.
Right.
Um,
ladies,
I dunno.
It's as it's endless and I can't wait to go,
but right before I do that or the day after assumption,
I'm going to be in Rochester,
New York,
Houma,
Steve Gadd,
uh,
with,
with Dean del Ray coming off lay marbles performance up at the just for laughs
festival.
Okay.
MMM.
Anyways,
uh,
I can't,
you know,
something,
that's the first time ever,
I'm actually starting to feel my God damn age,
you know,
and I was in Dallas,
the fact that I had like two shows and I wrote up sitting down in that frigging
car,
I'm you,
you know,
I was like,
like,
it seemed like I was,
I had to go shovel somebody driving.
Once they get out on the stage,
I'm fine.
But,
um,
actually I'm probably fine the whole time,
but I'm just like,
uh,
just the thought of it,
two shows never bugged me.
Three was always like,
all right,
what the fuck?
What am I working in a mine here.
I thought he got into show business to have a nice easy fucking life here.
MMM.
Yeah.
It has been like feeling my age,
so I got to get back to a,
I don't know what you know,
cause I shouldn't be feeling.
I might feel a little bit my fucking now,
so my,
my shoulder's fine and now my knee is fucked up.
I don't even know what the Hell I did to it.
Yeah.
Just crawling around,
playing with my daughter.
All of a sudden just my knee all of a sudden
felt like really?
I don't know what hot,
stinging pain,
but it's not constant and it's only when I put pressure on it,
so I don't think that it's bone to bone.
Thank God.
I think I've been active enough to have that shit.
This is one of my favorite things to do by the way,
is to let you guys know what some of my ailments are and then you guys all just
turn it.
The doctors.
It's one of my favorite things.
Go.
Do you know what that is?
It's actually your kidney.
Hear me out.
One time there was this guy,
right.
And it just fucking goes into that shit.
And he was out on the golf course.
You guys,
you know,
I'm at the doctor,
look at my,
my knees.
And the next day he died of a,
uh,
a kidney apparatus.
It kidney,
uh,
aorta,
what'd they call it?
Kidney Hemorrhage.
Cambridge.
Um,
Tony was eight,
that fucking little checklists of Aki in dish.
And then,
then I went right back to salads and I was fine and find a finding and late at
night,
these goddamn hotels,
they always get me,
they always had the little snack thing I'd eaten.
Perfect.
When I was in Houston,
unbelievably,
there was no snacks right now everybody knows Houston was voted,
uh,
unprecedented back to back.
They went back to back is the fattest city in America.
Okay.
And this is no,
you know,
it's not like these are,
this is some little fucking,
you're not going up against cupcakes here in America.
No Pun intended.
All right.
Where are some of the fattest people on the plan?
I don't even think we are.
I gotta be honest with you.
Maybe we are,
but collectively,
but when you're in the city,
she,
you know,
you don't see a lot of fat people.
You're in the city.
There's just too many eyes on you.
You know,
you get out in the country,
man.
I mean,
shit,
you can just walk your property book and Butt ass naked.
Who gives,
if you don't,
nobody cares how fat you get those overalls.
What we'll hide the,
the first 40 pounds.
Who's kidding?
Who remember Uncle Jesse,
that big goddamn beer belly he had,
but he had in the overall,
so you look,
he looked like Santa Claus just look good.
All Bar.
They have a main and no home.
It's dumb.
It's full of boobs and fucking regret.
He doesn't even know his kids.
Um,
was that what that whole thing was about?
He was uncle Jesse,
Boeing,
Lou quick cousins.
He must've come from a big family because that should have been odds out.
We should have been one of their dads.
Right.
Cooter okay.
It's crazy.
Cool.
Do you get your ears on?
Um,
I'm actually at the end of the sixth season.
Of a 77 sunset strip.
It got canceled after 20 episodes.
And I'm really gonna miss that show.
And I hope that me TV,
which I'm going to look up right now is going to go back to episode one again
cause I missed if they start,
I could have watched the whole series since last November and I didn't even know
it was on.
Um,
and I would love to,
I really wanted to see those first five episodes cause he was in la anytime they
weren't in La.
I would always hit pause just to see,
uh,
if I could recognize where they were.
There he goes,
me TV 77 sunset strip.
Come on man.
Give me a fucking showing.
Gimme a showing schedule is that when I send me seven has its roots in an
underrated,
I don't care about that.
Come on schedule,
watch.
It's going to be over.
I'm sorry.
We have no,
this things of that weeknights at 4:00 AM,
but they're going to start over again.
But you stopped.
I didn't get one on Thursday or Friday,
Thursday or Friday.
So,
um,
let me read some of the advertising hits.
We,
I,
I got nothing for you here this week guys.
The red sox speak to twins.
There's something,
we got the Phillies tonight for some more exciting inner league play.
They have inner league play like every fucking two days now.
You know,
they always go,
they always got to kill it.
The Yankees,
they're fucking big man there,
Aaron,
Judge Way Guy fucking chipped a bone in his hand.
You know,
it hit him right in the palm to mass gotta fucking killed,
you know,
sometimes they chip in your elbow seems like,
well it's Kinda sticking out so it wouldn't hurt that much.
It's designed for that.
Like,
you know,
the inside of your palm or chip that as far as like the worst bones to break his
another one cheekbone.
Yup.
Being filed.
I don't have fuck that.
Uh,
obviously you want to break your neck,
you can break a toe,
you know what I mean?
Like do you think if they were torturing you and they wanted you to give up
where the base was,
you could handle a broken toe,
right?
Ah,
I was so bad.
I'm still on that telling you.
Okay.
No,
once the,
once the guy goes to the rusty tools though,
it's,
it's like,
all right man,
what are we doing here?
What the fuck do you want to know?
I don't give a shit.
What are they going to call you?
Let me go.
I tell you,
I know you've got to kill me.
Let me just tell you where everything is and you just take out the drilling.
Hey,
smiley.
Okay.
Oh,
the itsy bitsy spider went up.
The what?
It's about.
Yeah.
How you doing?
You want me to read the boss baby again?
Oh,
you're excited,
Huh?
Whoa.
Oh,
whoa.
Bye.
See you later.
All right,
let's show off here.
Okay.
Uh,
laughing.
Crying.
Angry.
Surprise.
There you go.
Good job buddy.
She doesn't,
her toe is,
where's your toe?
Toe?
You know that word?
Yeah.
She tests her tone.
She looked in amazement toe.
Honey,
I have to read advertising here so I can keep buying your foods.
Huh?
He finding food?
Yeah.
That's how it works.
Come on,
baby.
All right.
Oh,
look at this first one.
Whoa.
Come on.
Oh,
it's okay buddy.
I'll be out there in a minute.
Oh my God.
She's holding her arms out.
Oh,
it's holding your arms out looking at me.
Oh boy.
Okay.
And now I have,
I have to
continue podcasting's under these circumstances.
All right.
First read of the week,
honey.
Millions of people are using honey to save money while shopping online.
And why wouldn't they?
It's very hostile.
It's free.
Takes just two clicks to add to your browser and saves you time and saves you
tons of money.
It's ingenious.
But one of my absolute favorite things about [inaudible] is how much better it
makes shopping on Amazon.
Um,
please personalize.
Personalize this to make it your own honey.
Madge.
Okay,
honey magically adds all sorts of useful information on the Amazon page of
whatever you're looking at.
I was supposed to,
right?
Am I supposed to make this personal?
Just shop like I normally do?
Hi honey.
Automatically searches the 2 million sellers on Amazon to find you the lowest
price.
It even shows you the items,
prices changes.
So you can decide if you want to buy or wait for the price to come up and down.
Did I read the right?
It even shows you is the,
the item's prices.
Prices changes its price changes.
Read it right.
If you do decide to wait,
just added to honeys,
drop lists and alum notify you.
If the price drops 100 he's got your back.
You'll never overpay for anything on Amazon again.
There's no reason to not to add honey to your browser today.
It's free and takes just two clicks to install and we'll make sure you always
get to the lowest price on Amazon.
Add honey to your browser for free right now@jointhoney.com slash burr that's
joined honey.com/ [inaudible] and note g
talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
Listen,
nobody checks out.
The fellas like me,
okay?
I put on my glasses,
I sit on a street corner and I just wait for them to sashay passed and I got to
admit,
I find time and time again,
I'm just attracted to a man in a suit.
It's confidence,
it's success.
It says,
I'm going places.
Take my wrist,
honey.
Um,
Indo Chino is the world's largest.
Why would you take as risk?
You take his arm,
right?
It's the world's largest made to measure men's wear company and has been
featured in major publications including Gq.
Ooh,
Forbes,
ah,
and fast company.
She keeping fast company.
They make suits and shirts made to your exact measurements for great fit.
Guys.
Love the wide,
the wide selection.
Thumb at the wide pants.
Like I know fat clientele guys love the wide selection of high quality fabrics
and the option to personalize all the details,
including your lapel w uh,
lining and monogram.
You got to have a lapel.
You know,
when you're wearing a suit.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Have to have a lapel just in case you disappoint somebody and they need
something to grab.
Here's how it works.
First a showroom or shop or shop online@indochino.com pick up your fabric.
Choose your customization to submit your measurements,
wait for your custom suit to arrive.
And just two weeks,
uh,
this week my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just $379.
At indochino.com I n d o,
c h,
I,
n o,
all capitals.com when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium for a made to
measure premium suit.
Imagine if I did this on vinyl and just got stuck may to Majia may dementia plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit for just $379
including free shipping,
including incredible deal for a soup.
They'll fit you better than anything off the rack ever could.
All right hotel tonight,
honey,
we have to fuck now.
Thank God there's hotel to hotel tonight is the Goto App for booking great deals
at great hotels.
Unlike other hotel booking sites,
hotel tonight doesn't have long,
endless lists of a zillion hotel choices.
Instead hotel tonight,
tonight to
Oh with uh,
well shows you the best deals at best hotels.
They partner with top rated hotels to help them fill their unsold rooms,
which is how you get such great deals.
And even though the name is hotel tonight,
it's not just for tonight.
You can book tonight,
tomorrow or beyond.
It's perfect for planners as well as procrastinators.
When you to be a town,
honey,
I can't play for the future.
You can book spontaneous weekends,
three day,
three day.
You get it.
A fucking threesome.
Getaways,
staycation,
road trips,
business trips.
You could dress up like a nurse.
You can book a hotel.
You just so you can use the pool,
et cetera.
Download the hotel tonight app today to get great deals at hotels you actually
want to stay at and with Promo Code Bar you can get $25 off your first eligible
booking hotel tonight.
Promo Code Burr.
Okay.
How many more of these I got to read.
All right,
three down.
Three to go.
We'll do one more then I'll give you a break.
All right.
What are we getting?
Borrow.
Okay.
No,
they're not selling.
Acid is owning a couch from hell is like a rite of passage.
I eat too expensive,
too heavy,
too cheap to warn.
You found it on a street corner and God knows who fucked on it.
A police use one is your negative couch experiences to contrast.
How amazing your new borough conscious.
Oh,
I used to live with Robert Kelly back in the day and uh,
I think Bobby Watch Sanford and son too much because he was constantly bringing
things in from the sidewalk.
One of these was the couch that he then put a bedspread over,
which was I guess supposed to block out the potential body lice or maybe broken
cracked pipe that you could sit on,
you know,
you know what do you know what I really wish
other than that I could hug Bob Right now and tell him that it was okay that he
took that couch off the sidewalk.
I really wished that burrow existed back then cause me and Bobby could have
fucking ordered a couch right after all these years of stuff.
Was that personal enough?
After all these years of suffering,
you owe it to yourself to experience the comfort and quality of a borough.
Couch.
Borough.
Borough brings style and comfort to a whole new level and shifts to your door
fast and free.
Your relationship with your couch will never be the same.
I've always loved you.
Burrow sofas are arrogant.
Sewickley designed so I'm comfortable while I uh,
what do you do most on borough?
Not off while watching me TV cause I think you know,
it's most comfortable while I not off to TV.
Customize Your Borough Sofa to match your style by selecting the color size,
armrest,
height and leg color armrest side.
Wow,
that's brilliant.
Shipping is fast and free unlike the rest of the future industry.
And did I mention it has a built in USB charger.
Wow.
This is sounding like you could take this thing to space.
Enjoy 30 days of cozy on your comfortable borough risk-free or try it out and
borrow at one of their partners showrooms today and then what?
You can bring it back,
rouse customize or it doesn't say that,
oh you can try it for free for 30 days.
Customize your own borrow and get $75 off your order by going to borrow.com/x x,
x,
x.
I guess that's supposed to be burr.
I was like,
I know some,
that's a weird one.
That's B U R r o w.com/x x x x.
No Burr,
fuck for $75 my fucking Ron Burgundy,
God it,
he'll read anything there slash burger or I should say for $75 off your purchase
borough makes the luxury couch for real.
Okay.
All right.
Let's get to some of the uh,
questions for this week.
I guess that's what we'll do.
We'll do a couple of questions and then we'll,
I can go back to some more advertising if I can actually figure out how to read
it.
All right.
Russia feeling left out.
Hey,
your bill bur rough.
Uh,
I've been listening to you,
you talking about your upcoming Eastern European tour in the latest podcast,
but not hearing about any stops in Russia leaves me quite scarred and
traumatized every time the podcast ends.
Is this guy making fun of millennials or how soft Americans are or are
millennials a worldwide problem?
I mean,
what's the deal with leaving us out?
Stand up is very popular here right now.
Stand up in Russia.
I mean,
you allowed to talk about anything.
I can't see going over there doing a Vladimir Putin fucking impression could I?
Then what happens?
All of a sudden somebody sprays some mist on me and I'm sure you can easily pack
a full show several times over in places like Moscow and Saint Petersburg.
Uh,
besides think of all the experiences you can have in the Oji Vodka capitol of
the world.
It's dirt cheap with the current exchange rates.
The cities are beautiful and quite different from what you see anywhere else.
The people are friendly,
welcoming,
and fun loving.
Was this written by the KGB or is this really a regular person?
You never know.
I mean,
we haven't gotten along for a long time.
I know it kind of died down for a minute,
but you know,
it's always going to be Yankees and red sox with us,
unfortunately.
Um,
to be honest with you,
dude,
I'm actually,
I was talking to my agent about trying to add Moscow,
um,
which I shouldn't have said because not everybody is always trying to add it.
And then if I don't,
then I'm a fucking asshole.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I know we have a bad rap currently.
Even heard,
you mentioned that gay people and journalists have been killed here,
which would be laughable to us if not so many people believe those stories.
Uh
Oh,
you don't think,
oh my God,
am I who's living under the right media bubble?
Anyways,
but let me ask,
just ask you one thing.
If you're so skeptical about trusting the media in your everyday life,
why go around and believe what that same media is spewing about other countries?
Not Saying you should take my word for it.
Come and see for yourself.
Hey,
come on over,
Bill.
We're not killing anybody over here.
Grab it.
Make your own decision and the meantime,
give a little gift of laughter to melt are cold.
My strikes,
chef,
loving hearts.
I don't even want to say it.
Have a nice day and go fuck yourself.
Oh Man.
Um,
no.
I would love to fucking go over there and uh,
I dunno what the fuck the belief,
but I do know this a,
we're not the only one's lying,
you know?
Okay.
It's don't believe the American media,
but believe my media about my country.
Well,
I guess maybe I should believe.
I mean,
look,
I don't think I would if I went over there.
Yeah,
it would be honest.
I Dunno.
Maybe you're being honest.
Who the fuck knows?
You know,
I think we should just grow up and joined forces.
Um,
okay.
A RP.
Oh,
hi bill.
I've heard on your podcast that you was,
oh wait,
by the way,
have you guys seen the Vladimir Putin fucking goes out and plays hockey and
they're just letting them score right and left.
I got a fucking post that video,
you know,
that's that type of shit.
You know what I mean?
Like do you think they'd let Donald Trump score?
They probably would,
but we always had that thing all,
they're not like they're letting them score cause they don't want to get sent to
Siberia.
Um,
a high bill.
Hey,
you know something?
I would like to hear from more Russian people.
I want you guys to infiltrate my fucking podcast here.
Like you did the last election.
Oh,
a hot take.
I don't even know if he did that.
Um,
I have no idea.
I don't pay,
I don't watch the news.
Um,
a ARP,
hi bill.
I heard on your podcast that you received a r p invitation to join.
The biggest benefit we get from arp is that it is a very large lobbyists for us.
Old People.
Please join.
Thanks.
Oh my God.
Did I just joined a group?
Um,
yeah.
For those of you didn't listen last week I tr uh,
I'm 50 years old now.
Mooc makes me qualified for Aa,
our P and I can,
I can go to the movies for like $8.
You know,
I can get a custom cane walking cane or something if I want.
There's a whole bunch of things I can do.
Um,
I'm actually,
you know what,
I was on the road and I saw there was an email.
It was something I needed to fill out.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead further.
You know,
I gotta be honest with you guys,
I'm always honest on this podcast.
Last night,
yeah.
Had this little square of fucking weed and she goes,
take a bite of it.
I got,
I hate eating wheat.
I don't like eating it.
And she goes,
no,
just try as like,
I don't,
I don't want to do.
So she talks me into it.
I'm eating dinner and I ate the fucking thing and I never really felt anything.
And about 10 minutes ago on this podcast of a sudden it fucking hit me like 12
hours later.
You know,
I'm not like fucking tripping,
but I think that's why I was reading like x,
x,
x twice instead of once.
I have no idea.
I thought this shit is supposed to make it clearer.
Okay.
I really Miss Booze.
I mean,
you just kind of know what's going to happen.
Like what,
what's going on right now?
Is this like some Bruce Lee shit.
It's my brain swell up now and I just keel over on my own podcast.
Um,
anyways,
nutrition.
You goofy,
bald headed baldheaded potato looking.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
You're harsh in the mellow man.
I know.
You were looking to go to a nutritionist for advice.
Be warned.
This industry isn't particularly well-regulated.
Yeah,
I know.
It's terrifying.
Basically once they,
they have that degree,
they don't have any oversight like real doctors.
If they fuck you over,
there's only so much that you can do.
Well I could sue them,
but the already saying they don't have the money of a doctor.
So what's the point?
A here's what you should do.
A find a nutritionist that provides advice based on lab work.
Most of these cuts we'll just have you keep a food journal and then give you
advice based on what you ate over the week.
This is stupid and it can be both misleading and inaccurate.
Not to mention expensive
lab
for finance person that provides advice based on lab work.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's can't you just fucking sit there thrown out stats.
Four to five doctors recommended this has barriers.
Um,
anyways,
be whatever product they get you to start taking.
Ask them if they get money for the referral and what are they going to say?
Yes,
I'm a good nutritionist.
Won't try to sell you something just because they get a kickback and an even
better one.
We'll give you a list of options of things you could do based on your blood
work.
And I make this all makes sense,
I guess.
Hey,
people that have to give their opinion,
give you their credentials as a means of validating their opinion.
But for context,
I'm a member of Team USA and competed in the 2006 Olympics in Rio.
Jesus Christ,
it fucking thrown your Dick on the table here.
The only reason why I say this is that a is for the example that team USA is
sponsored by Coca Cola and even our nutritionist attempt to hook us up on
protein brand,
um,
on a protein brand owned by coke.
Yeah.
It's how it works.
Everybody has a side deal despite it being an inferior and more expensive
product.
Wow.
They recommended it to the athletes,
isn't that,
and there was,
and there was gold medals on the line anyways,
just saying,
be careful who you listen to.
They even do elite athletes with this shit.
Well,
you know what?
That's probably one of the most informed fucking emails I ever read or are.
Yeah,
I guess it is an email write letter.
And I was like,
oh,
when I was a kid,
they called him letters.
Yeah,
I know.
I have to watch out for that.
I'm one of the reasons I got a nutrition in this.
It is because,
um,
when I went online,
anything that I looked up about food,
I mean the whole front,
I don't know how many pages was just all big time websites and um,
and then just confirm everything was conflicting.
You know,
these are good.
Don't eat those.
I'll tell you he got belly flat.
You know what the problem is?
Bananas.
A lot of people think banana is a fucking just like,
you know,
I don't know how long when people do that.
You start telling you like certain fruits and vegetables are bad for you.
It's like,
yeah,
well I imagine if I eat a fucking Bushel,
love him.
It's not good.
But isn't it also like some sort of a potassium or some shit I get out of
bananas.
I Dunno.
Gorillas eat them.
They look pretty fucking buff.
A 23.
And me,
uh,
here's the old Billy cito.
Oh,
hey there Billy.
Ultimately Cheeto Dick.
Oh Man.
Come on man.
A link to the article at the bottom,
but I know you don't read.
So here's the gist.
All right,
hang on a second.
23 and me is getting lots of money from big pharmacy.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Anyway,
he goes,
all right.
He goes,
you were absolutely right.
This company,
23 and me is set to make 300 million from sharing their users generic
information with big pharmacy.
Oh,
is that one of those,
uh,
okay.
Like ancestry.com websites.
Uh,
they say it's so the bank company can use the data to develop medical
breakthroughs,
Isam ship.
But I'm sure we all know that's bullshit except,
except to see robot replacements within a decade or two anyway,
so you could use some vindication from a fellow conspiracy nuts,
have a good one and go swap your own spit,
go fuck yourself.
Um,
I would actually guess that
all of that is true.
Okay.
They're going to use all of that information,
um,
to develop new drugs,
I would think because they're trying to make money,
none of which will cure you.
They'll just keep you up,
you know,
on the hook.
We'll keep them all just alive enough that he keeps buying her a little pill.
Um,
and then I also think the robots are going to come.
Absolutely.
You know,
but the bottom line is,
is the people who are making the robots are overseeing it.
Earl so human.
So it's in their best interest to try and cure shit for other humans.
Right.
I already told you my philosophy.
Am I fucking theory was basically,
I should've told you guys about that fucking stupid pot square thing.
Cause right now you're like oh man,
this is just cause he's high.
You know,
fucking people who are like into,
we'd always give it credit.
You know,
like I didn't already have this thought.
I had this paranoid thought stone sober alone in a hotel room.
This is what I think.
I think that they're going to fucking use that shit to build robots and then
they're going to kill everybody off,
keep a certain amount of people alive and their job's going to be to like keep
reproducing so the Illuminati can harvest the organs.
I swear to God that's got to be from the weed man.
No,
I swear to God,
I've actually said that on stage this weekend.
Stone's Silva after eating a salad.
You know,
a lot of those salads actually have chemicals sprayed all over him.
So you're actually,
I know,
I know.
There's no fucking way around it.
Alright,
Bill from a lady,
uh,
hey,
build the blahzay blahzay cunt,
the Blazo Kat,
um,
I'm a relatively recent listener of your podcast as if seeing you at cluster
fest in San Francisco a year ago.
MMM.
That sentence makes no sense.
I am a relatively recent listener of your podcast as of seeing you at cluster
fest in San Francisco a year ago.
All right.
I guess that does make sense,
but it's kind of written it up.
Passive aggressive Shakespearian way.
You could've fucking arranges the letters a little more,
uh,
straightforward there.
All right.
I'm not going to lie.
That one right there.
That was the weed.
I literally have a meeting in a half hour.
Like what the f I'm just going to fuck.
I can't imagine the show I'm going to agree to do.
All right.
Not Looking where I was going.
I almost accidentally walked into you while you were on your way to interview
Jerry Seinfeld.
Uh,
most of the same way.
I probably came off as rude from my deer in the headlight moments of literally
running into one of the best comedians of all time that I write this.
So I hope you can accept my late apology.
Yeah.
What am I in fucking in Lord of the rings here?
Yeah,
I see.
You are forgiven.
She is spared.
I thought your interview and headliner act was terrific and hope to see another
one of your shows.
That was one of the coolest fucking days ever,
by the way.
I fucking got,
got to do a and [inaudible] show that day.
No,
it was,
it was the day after I'd finished my show the next day.
Uh,
I got to interview Jerry Seinfeld in a theater in front of them,
I don't know,
a couple thousand people while he promoted the latest season of comedians in
cars.
Had a great time.
And then I walked out the door and,
uh,
had a car service to go over.
Okay.
With Josh Adam Meyers.
We had booked a car service to go into the NBA finals to see like game three of
the NBA finals.
Um,
golden state versus the Cleveland Warriors and the driver was so cool.
He let us smoke cigars in the back.
Come on man.
Great fucking days of my life.
Anyways.
Um,
I'm glad you mentioned you wanted more women to write to your show.
I would love,
yeah,
cause I love trashing you.
No,
I'm kidding.
I would like to hear what it is.
Shit you think I would love if you had more female guests on your podcast.
Oh Geez.
I don't think I've ever had a woman on my,
does that mean on sexist,
sexist,
sexist?
I don't think I actually appealed to women.
And I can tell you why.
Because my shows a sausage fest and when I go outside I can't even tell you how
many times somebody will be like,
it'll be a couple and they want a picture and like the wife or girlfriend takes
the picture and they never want one.
Just the guy does.
So I mean,
I dunno.
I think maybe this is just like a,
okay.
I Dunno.
I'm trying to think of something that's so strictly for guys like footballs,
you know,
basically that version.
I'm trying to pick something when actually offend women footballs and for
everybody.
Anyways,
I was wondering if you could give me some dating advice.
Yeah.
Um,
society generally teaches women at a young age that men are suitors and women
are courted.
But as a 27 year old woman who dates women,
sometimes it gets particularly difficult to figure out who does what role,
especially if both women are very feminine.
Well,
at that point you got to step it up.
Also just be a staring contest,
right?
Sometimes these roles just fit naturally,
but other times there isn't a clear sense of direction and the whole thing just
falls apart.
Let me asked you this.
All right.
Because opposites attract.
They always say,
um,
and I've dated people who are too similar to me and it's just,
we want a yin and a Yang.
We would to yangs.
So we had half the fucking thing taken care of and the rest was a shit show.
So when the lesbian world,
all right,
if both women are feminine,
does that have less of a chance of making it as a relationship we want to hear
from lesbians were taking college it fat,
fat,
fat.
Uh,
sometimes these roles just fit naturally,
but other times there isn't a clear sense of direction and the whole thing just
falls apart.
I'm also not naturally comfortable with approaching women at bars or social
events that eventually wait for someone else to make the first move.
Risa,
why you got all the power?
Because it's,
it's,
it's all women,
right?
So there's no fucking,
there's nothing,
there's nothing holding you back here other than that voice in your head going,
what if she says no?
Recently,
I feel like I've missed out on some good opportunities for dates because of
this.
What advice would you give to someone who isn't used to being the proactive or
leading role in a dating situation?
Uh,
thanks and best wishes to your family.
Oh yeah.
And Go fuck yourself.
Well,
why don't you just start hitting on somebody you're not interested in.
You don't just as practice and just say that stupidest,
dumbest,
most over the top shit.
I mean,
I'm applying to this
two as a guy,
if you're afraid to talk to women,
it's kind of like a,
you got to see the humor in it.
You guys see the humor and getting up thinking someone gave you a look like,
yeah,
I'm in to you.
And you walk all the way over there and it turns out they were looking at
somebody else or whatever you say to them,
just completely bombs.
And then instantly in that moment,
you know,
I should just turn around and walk back to where I was,
but just out of some stupid pride,
you'll continue to stand there for 10 minutes,
no adding rather than ripping the bandaid off,
just slowly tearing it off so that person can reject you for another fucking
sixth of an hour.
Um,
oh,
she said,
ps,
I've been Vegan for six plus years and found it does work.
It does wonders for my health.
Changing my diet,
literally cured a moderate skin condition I had since I was a child.
Uh,
if you're still curious about giving ved veganism a trust,
a test run,
sorry.
I'd say try it out for a month and see how you feel.
It definitely works for me,
but I know that's not the case for everyone and tries it.
Um,
yeah,
I'm trying to be lazy about learning how to do it.
I just like go to a nutritionist,
teach me,
you know,
I was just like,
hang out with somebody that's,
you know,
show me some,
just give me a fucking bitch.
You know what?
I wish they just had like a giant march madness like poster for how to be a
Vegan,
like that.
Easy.
You know what I mean?
Like you look okay,
these two teams play.
Now,
this team's names here,
so I know it won that game.
I wish they could just fucking do that and break it down and the bracket leads
to the finals,
which is protein or at least the fucking,
whatever the fuck,
whatever else you need.
Carbohydrates.
I don't fucking know.
I swear to God,
I am literally going to assume my girl,
my wife for fucking drug in me here.
I came to keep my fucking thoughts straight at this point.
Um,
girlfriends,
arguably racist family.
Oh boy.
Oh Jesus.
Uh,
I'm a black guy in Louisiana with the girlfriend who is white.
Her family is very religious and reserved as am I.
Although we are kind of religious,
her and I,
not our families per se where we have our beliefs and don't shut them down
people's throats.
Anyways,
the problem is she has had,
she had a kid with a black guy right before I met her.
All right.
She has a type,
her kid is not even six months.
He left her high and dry and wants nothing to do with them.
Now seeing as we are in the south,
I asked her a normal question down here,
is your family okay with you dating a black guy?
That question gets asked all over the country.
By the way,
it's,
there's this myth that racism is just down in the south.
Um,
she was very honest and said,
Eh,
my mom and dad should be fine.
He eats fried chicken every Sunday.
So you'd love him.
She said that my grandparents generation,
uh,
not so much.
Well,
she was making,
I guess this is a joke.
This is one like reading it.
You're like,
I don't know how this was set anyways.
Fair enough.
I'll work with that.
The problem is after she talked me up to her mom
and her mom saw a picture of me,
she was like,
oh no,
he's black.
You just going to get hurt.
So I don't know if her mom was just an error.
Okay.
Inherit,
oh,
inherited the races more if she feels that way,
because a black guy ditched her pregnant daughter.
Uh,
how do I approach this?
They live in the woods.
Jesus Christ.
This sounds like fucking Tarantino movie.
You know,
one of those little shorts that he makes,
you know,
and going back to visit them is kind of sketchy to me.
And I haven't told my mom because she'd have an aneurysm.
Yeah.
Don't go in the woods of fucking Louisiana to fucking visit some feels like get
out.
Don't fucking do that.
And that kid.
Yeah,
the chicken.
Oh,
wait a minute.
This is get out you motherfucker.
Is that what this is?
Oh,
I've been had,
you know what?
That's embarrassing.
Anyways.
Rough and rowdy broke.
No,
wait,
is it,
did she get pregnant that movie?
No.
I don't know if that's real enough.
Hey,
Nia,
she probably left.
Left the scene of the crime.
All right,
well I've got a couple more advertisements to read here.
Okay.
Oh,
the black Tux,
everybody.
Yes.
And actually the black Tux.
Oh,
Jesus.
Wedding season is upon us there.
He's getting married in the summer,
right?
If they're broke ass couple,
there's no air conditioning in the fucking church.
And then they're the,
they're the ones always want to have the long fucking religious ceremony.
Um,
wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big and going out to all of your buddies weddings.
When you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
That's where the Black Tux,
Trump's in the black tux has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles
and you rent them online.
The black Tux offers the kind of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly,
wildly expensive to buy.
And you might've only wear it once
like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's funky.
It's cool.
How many times are you going to wear an Emerald Green Tuxedo with the the black
Tux you can do,
you can do you do you man and blow it out for your big one time event.
So try a new look,
do something different and take your style to the next level.
With the Black Tux,
a Tux free home.
Try on,
you can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
And remember how simple returns are a,
where are Jesus Christ almost?
I forgot how to speak English or where it turned heads.
Then send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/bar that's the black tux.com/birth for $20 off your
purchase.
The Black Tux,
premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
And lastly,
but not leastly simply safe,
simply safe.
These guys obsess over the details and it's why the alarm system is so good.
Here's an example.
A typical glass breaks since sometimes gets fooled of false positive sounds like
drop plates,
a baby crying.
Uh,
I was,
I supposed to like,
here's an example.
Was I supposed to like try to make a funny example?
I never know what this copy simply safe,
uh,
didn't want to settle for typical because really good home security should be
really accurate.
So they actually constructed a glass break,
test facility off something breaks.
Scholastica okay,
just give me a break.
Glass Test Facility class break.
They ran over 10,000 live glass breaks situations,
refining their detection technology.
It was so accurate.
It could distinguish a broken plate from a broken window.
How fucking boring was that?
And what does it,
some guy looking at like the,
the,
the volume to see if it's the same sound wave to get 500 different sounds of
broken glass.
What if somebody breaks a window with a wine glass?
Honey,
sorry,
I'm not going to be home tonight.
Yeah,
I got a break.
Uh,
you know,
I got to see what happens when you frisbee a plate into some fucking stained
glass.
Um,
but you know what?
God bless these guys for doing it.
This is the level of detail.
Simply safe puts into everything they do.
They're the Daniel Day Lewis of breaking glass.
It's sets them apart from other security companies.
Simply safe system is designed so you'll never notice it.
Never have to think about it.
It's that.
It's that easy and intuitive.
There's no contract.
They work hard to earn your business.
24,
seven monitoring with police and fire dispatch.
It's just $15 a month.
It's the best around the clock protection.
You can find or do you simply safe security system today.
It's simply safer.com and simply safe.
We'll donate one,
uh,
to a family in need that simply safe for.com simply safe for.com.
It's an I know why it's simply,
all right.
That's going to be the podcast,
um,
for Monday,
July 30th.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Have a great week and go fuck yourselves.